to sit back as a defensive player
and learn from coach belichick what
you're supposed to do in a situation
like that
it's it's it's really crazy for me
because when you look at this play don't
look at the offense i want you to look
in i want you to look in the end zone
and look at the safeties look how far
deep they are in the end zone and that's
harrison smith he's a veteran player
he's an all-pro player you don't ever as
a db sit in the end zone you stand at
the goal line because if they come in
front of you and they catch the ball
it's a touchdown we're taught everybody
needs to be at the goal line don't be in
the end zone because all they have to do
is come in front of you catch the ball
and it's a touchdown those are little
simple things little fundamentals and
and zimmer used to be one of the best
defensive coordinators around all of nfl
football and all of a sudden you see
things like this and it just doesn't
make sense you got
what is this eight guys dropping in the
end zone and you can't stop one that
means you can actually double cover
every receiver out on the football field
why is number 23 sitting in the end zone
what is that gonna do for you it's just
crazy for me and then teams wonder why
coaches get fired players get cut
because it's those small things it's the
fundamentals of football and it's
amazing to me that
that who's ever calling that whether
it's zimmer or his defensive coordinator
like how do you sit there and watch that
as a coach and see three safeties deep
in the end zone why wouldn't you call a
timeout it's just frustrating to me
right that's a game they have to win and
you made a great point about the
importance of that kind of a loss as you
as you look towards the playoffs as well
and this is a game where kirk cousins as
much flack as we have given him kirk
cousins played a really good game
watching this back justin jefferson had
a huge game they ran the ball well they
scored points so that's where it goes
full circle right back to zember's
defense and let's give a little bit of
credit on the other side of the thing to
the detroit lions because the detroit
lions are a team that has struggled so
much throughout this year in terms of
losing but they have been so tough in
terms of competing every game it just
seems like they're in it right till the
end they play so hard they want to win
for their coach they love their coach if
you saw that scene in the locker room
afterwards and they finally got one done
i kind of like what's happening with
detroit's it's a definite rebuild and
they know that and jared goff's got to
go from la to detroit does he want to no
but it does seem like there is really
some awesome relationships developing
between their players and their coach
and they're playing hard for him
absolutely i just um
i i got to give a lot of crop props to
the detroit lions i mean i was on the
team that was one and 15 and i think it
was the 11th week of the season when we
played we end up beating um the kansas
city chiefs and it felt like it was the
super bowl and you know to get up every
single day get in there and lift weights
to work out to practice meetings study
get the massages cool tub hot tub your
whole your whole day your process and to
be able to lose every single week is
disheartening it's very difficult to
come to work i don't care how many zeros
those checks have on them but at the end
of the day you play this game because
not only do you want to get paid you
want to win football games and i'm just
so happy for dan campbell he played he's
passionate the lions are prepared every
time they come out they fight in their
claw they don't have the most talented
guys but they have a group of guys that
believe in their coach and if i'm if i'm
detroit i'm going to i'm going to jarrod
golf and say hey man if you want to help
us become a better team you need to take
a pay cut he needs to redo his contract
take up take a pay cut and maybe put it
in incentives to help detroit laurel
lure some more free agents over there
because that's what they need they need
more talent
yeah that's interesting that's probably
true as well i agree with you there all
right let's get to number two on turn
the page tuesday which is the cincinnati
bengals so the bengals are one of those
teams they can beat anybody and they can
lose to anybody and they got no problem
doing either one of them where is that
coming from for the cincinnati bengals
well we sit by each other every single
sunday and we watch the bengals and it's
just kind of up and down it's a roller
coaster ride and what you have to
understand with the bengals is
they're a very young team but they're
very talented teams so with young teams
you're going to get inconsistent play
and you just hope that it doesn't come
from the quarterback but you look at
jamar chase and how he's been dropping
the passes then he looks great then he
drops other passes and you just look at
the inconsistency of their team and yeah
you could blame the head coach to a
certain degree but this is a young team
and they're trying to figure out how to
win football games and the more
experience they get the more
opportunities and this is chase
jamar chase you got to make this play i
mean you just have to make this play you
know your nfl wide receiver jack
[Music]
i mean he's running down the field i
mean that's just a perfect throw from
joe burrow that could have been a
touchdown right i mean that is just a
perfect throw and this is what we saw in
the preseason he had erased it and now
it's creeping back in and that's where i
agree with you in terms of being a young
team and i'm just looking at the most
drops around the league depot samuel has
nine tyree kill has nine we saw issues
with that with him on sunday night
football but the guy who was in third
with eight there's only one guy with
eight drops in the league is jamar chase
so he is top three in the entire nfl and
dropped passes this year so it's not
just a pre-season thing it's something
that's following him at this point and i
think joe burrow can pull him aside and
do certain things but it may just be a
part of the experience with jamar chase
the biggest thing i worry about with the
bengals right now is that pinky finger
of joe burrow because that is an
important finger when you're trying to
grip a football it's one of the last
ones that come off it when you're trying
to create a spiral so i'm a little bit
worried about how blown up that pinky
finger was in terms of the swelling on
joe burrow after he took that hit
yeah he looked like he was really
frustrated and a lot of pain on the
sideline when he was trying to throw he
threw his helmet down yelled and
discussed so that's something that i'm
definitely concerned about as well
that's right he's one tough sob though
the fact that he just keeps coming right
back in the game like it was never even
a conversation so here's the play that
he hurt that finger on here it is you
can kind of see he kind of gets grabbed
right there from behind
pass rusher coming around it just gets
that right hand of burro he comes right
back in the game he's still throwing it
but you could just tell the discomfort
and then when you look at it the
swelling was evident so tough situation
right there let's get to the la rams the
rams finally get a win after a tough
skid what page do you think they need to
turn though there in la
well they just got to keep playing you
know they got to keep playing and the
thing that stood out to both of us when
you know whenever we watch and play it's
just a lack of physicality and i started
thinking well maybe it's because they're
california their dome team or maybe it's
just the personnel that they have
but if you're if you're getting beat up
up front and matthew stafford he's
dropping back and he has zero confidence
in our offensive line and every time he
drops back he feels like he's going to
get hit you're going to see a different
matthew stafford we'll see if this game
propels them and builds some confidence
but i just don't see the same rams team
on defense on offense flying around that
we saw earlier when they played against
the chicago bears when we had that game
jack
yeah yeah i don't think like just
beating jacksonville fixes everything
right it's not a it's not a cure-all
for all the woes that they've had this
past month it's just a win and sometimes
you just desperately need a win and they
certainly did and maybe that springs
them forward but i don't think beating
jacksonville fixes everything they've
had probably the plus side for them has
been that odell beckham jr is starting
to become something he's starting to
become a factor in this offense and if
odell can start to pick up some of that
slack right they have injuries at the
wide receiver position if they can give
cooper cup another option there another
great option on the other side he can
just check all the ego stuff at the door
and just focus on football he could
become a legitimate weapon for them and
i think we're starting to see that with
the obj there was his touchdown this
week and you know and he can be a weapon
i mean he has to continue to build his
confidence in the system and everything
that you know that they're trying to do
but at the end of the day they're still
going to have to you know have to worry
about running the football they got to
run the football it can't be all matthew
stafford we've seen this year when it's
all matthew stafford what happens the
offense line breaks down they have some
they have some breakdowns and then all
of a sudden it's an interception or it's
a sack or it's a strip sack of things
like that if you can't run the football
if they can't run the football and sean
mcvay understands this matthew stafford
will be in trouble
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports